SPEAKER: Here at
Google, we continue
to see a lot of developers
building their APIs on top
of microservices.
So in this example, we've
deployed a weather API
on Cloud Run.
It's made up of four
different services.
This is great for you,
as an API provider,
because it gives you
a lot of flexibility
around how you deploy and
how you scale these services.
But as an API
consumer, you don't
want to keep track
of which service
is responsible for
which piece of the API.
You just want one
interface that you
can call to access all
the capabilities provided
by this API.
So let's take a look at how
Google Cloud's API Gateway can
help you combine all
these services into one
easy-to-use API.
To get started, we'll need
an open API specification
that defines each of the
resources in our API.
Next, we'll add
instructions to tell the API
Gateway where to route
the request for each
of those resources.
Finally, we'll want
to secure our API,
so we'll configure a
security definition
that requires all incoming calls
to provide a valid API key.
Once we have our open
API specification,
we're ready to create
our API gateway.
First, we'll specify
the display name
and give our API a
unique identifier.
Next, we'll define the
API's initial configuration
by uploading our open API file.
We'll then give our
configuration a Display Name
and we'll configure
the Service Account
that will be used to call
our backend services.
Finally, we're ready to
deploy our API configuration
to a new gateway.
In this case, that gateway will
run in the US Central region.
Once we hit Create,
after a few minutes,
our gateway will be ready to
start accepting incoming API
requests.
Because we've secured our API,
we'll need valid credentials.
In this case, we've elected to
use API keys as our security
mechanism.
We can get an API key for our
API in the APIs and Services
section of the
Google Cloud Console.
Once we have our key,
we can make an API call
from the command
line using curl.
If we try to access our API
without providing a key,
the call will be
rejected by the Gateway.
Once we add our
key to the request,
the Gateway then allows our
call to go through successfully.
That was just a
quick preview of how
you can use the new API Gateway
to create and secure your APIs.